oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to captive audience this is
not a web browser this is not a website
this is this is the game it's just
opened up like this what is it incident
Oh fire ah I might have broken it nerves
in hello hello and welcome to another
episode of lights camera catastrophe yes
yes today we have a very special show
for you though let's be honest
aren't they all a man who needs no
introduction
yeah draw he's been named in your home
for the last two decades give it up for
Harry caldera mom truly fantastic now
Harry
may I call you Harry oh cool your career
is nothing short of legendary for 20
years your work has been beamed to every
household in the world and into our
hearts who can forget such titles as
Susan housewife of the 80s
Barry and Chuck close-quarters and of
course Tommy and the tiger your
short-lived and rather gory but
exemplary miniseries that made us laugh
love and cry now you knew this was going
to come up and I'll apologize in advance
it's quite oh I bet you can captive
audience your most successful and
controversial show it ran for five
seasons five whole years before
catastrophe struck the production some
regarded as your greatest success others
a total failure I know you were even
called upon by the ethics council
investigating the incident tell us tell
us how that one got away oh you're not
gonna tell us I have no idea what's
going on they said something about there
being an incident and
it is a punishment please arrive
promptly huh
so we'd have a weap plan I have a weed
plan right son
my top on top all right that's all there
is to our and I didn't need any more but
I'm still no closer to finding you Jules
who turned the light off are y'all there
there oh hi Jules
I'm really sorry about that I guess oh
oh is that my throw arc oh yeah he'll
never leave me mr. blinky and now
they'll never find you behind the weed
where they will go straight to the floor
whoa I don't like oh my god there's a
spotlight on the [ __ ] all right can I
shower at least oh good hygiene is
important thank you for noticing
I guess hi Matt how are you I'm doing
great thanks even by another you guys
are fantastic and what will you be doing
for us today looks like today I'll be
doing some baking how does red velvet
cake sound Oh delightful
tell us what do you need for a cake like
that the recipe says I'll need butter
eggs flour salt sugar pickle juice well
that's different
also food coloring Mel
and frosting well better get to it then
man we don't want to keep the folks at
home waiting too long
Oh No wouldn't want to do that no way no
how
I'm gonna bake a cake just before I
explore everything in the room of
questionable frames-per-second I'm gonna
watch some TV apparently I didn't whoa
okay look looks a little close I didn't
mean to do that
that was my bad I was just thinking that
maybe Oh complacent in video games may
be a bit galactic Oh okay never mind
maybe a nice movie hello buddy how are
you this is exciting it's like some kind
of a Truman Show thing going on here
record maybe I'll put on some slammin
tunes hope it's royalty-free do I still
have it put it in there we go wow that
is some good stuff you can notice the
most social selves and instruments of
vinyl
[Music]
okay dog show yeah I could use some
company
good question I looked up some porn
while everybody's watching no booth I
wish I could see where I was throwing it
here we go here we go
damn damn oh I am indeed the most
interesting person on the face of the
planet well that was stupid and a waste
of time hello MooMoo I'm cousin blankie
okay okay that's really sad all right
anything in the fridge oh we got milk
we definitely got me is this gonna be
baking simulator all over again
Oh pickled onions cabbage all right sure
yeah good cheese I don't think we need
cheese but I like cheese okay I like
cheese in my red velvet egg good oh okay
good I got agar okay how about maybe
that's butter maybe that is that butter
and milk milk milk or poor milk milk it
is baking simulator it's butter
I'm hoping pickle juice very very
questionable but okay sure we're gonna
go pickle juice
sploosh all right just a - I guess slam
that back in the fridge okay never mind
I'm salt sure okay
buns oh um sure glad everyone's watching
this flower got it sugar done Kenny one
more egg there was only one egg oh there
was twig never mind
Edgar and
call it a ring I mean this is red so I
can only assume right blue oh okay sure
every heat on ish grab put okay sure yep
that'll did you get whatever okay I
don't know hope um
burn so I was baking a lovely cake
huh oh hey I got you oh ouch that that
really smarts
oh no that has got to hurt safety first
Matt maybe try the oven gloves silly me
definitely I thought of that sooner oh
no I smell burning
looks like you overcooked it Matt did
you get distracted come on let you just
put it in gosh yeah I should have paid
more attention folks huh maybe the
frosting will cover it up I'll do my
best okay
yeah well boy this is a exciting show
that everybody loves cuz why wouldn't
they frosting it is is it frosting okay
it looks like frosting this is not
that's powdered sugar no frosting sugar
oh I see okay
a little more sugar all right I guess
we're done that looks great Matt you
really brought it back now how does it
taste
uh-huh I had quite a big breakfast so
I'll save it for later
oh come now Matt the folks at home want
to know what it tastes like
and we all know you love cake sure do
buddy so Matt how's it taste
you look a bit ill there Matt next time
maybe you should follow the recipe a bit
closer oh hi everybody
see let's see you next time
broadcast ended please use this free
time to better yourself before the next
performance oh oh better myself okay
thank you I feel better already
I feel better about everything that's
going on in here I mean I get the
concept but Emily Oh what I'm not gonna
listen to you anymore but I don't even
know if I had an option to listen well
time to hit the old dusty trail Oh Oh
Stacie
hi honey how was your day just gossip
gossip gossip I mean could you just shut
up how are you holding up
it sounded like a rough one today it was
fine but I couldn't handle how about you
same here
maybe we'll get Council next season you
might actually get out people have to be
getting bored of this by now Matt if you
get canceled they don't just let you out
probably right just heard some form in
the kitchen must be careful they could
just be trying to bait you out some
stupid game yeah keep it out just a beer
at backup eyes okay I'll be here it's
not like I've got anywhere else to go
huh okay so I didn't even really I
didn't even realize for a while that
that was someone through the wall but
that makes sense
hello hello anyone here hello guess it's
on the fritz figures they can't even
keep their own gear running
and carefully follow my instructions and
I can help you it's time to stand here
here it doesn't matter who I am I'm a
friend
it matters to me trust me I'm the key to
your escape escape how this entire place
is like a fortress to just punish me if
I try anything just that easy huh okay
alright well okay but I saw a big
floating eyeball that seems bad
okay I'm going I guess yeah that's my
chance chance freedom it's gonna be a
big no-no I realize it's risky but still
ratings are in this lump and I think
this could be the thing that brings us
back into the limelight you've got to
trust me on this
give me a week maybe two we'll see how
it's going if it fails we could just
cancel the show and move on no big deal
but I'm telling you it's gonna be huge
while I remember
can you send down maintenance to remove
those bloody boxes it's a tripping
hazard we're trying to move the
equipment Thanks okay all right
I don't even know if I wanted to go that
way but I I think that was the host that
was talking over there if I'm not
mistaken
oh hey how you doing hi oh hi oh okay
you got it man
you got it don't ask questions about how
I escaped a little bit but don't worry
about it maybe if I build a fort I can
hide in it they'll never be able to
breathe what they're doing to you yeah I
guess so that's not the person through
the wall that's Stacey ah I got trapped
okay take deuce drop deuce can't take a
deuce can I drop today looks like I'm
gonna be playing a new video game today
I sure can't wait
terrific we'll get to it then doesn't
that game look fantastic
oh it looks great but I need to find a
controller first now where could it be
where could it be all those good banter
thanks buddy Oh controller - let's see
how we play I've got a good feeling that
we'll win this in no time
oh yeah in no time baby partly because
I'm extremely good at games okay all
right here we go I'll pop to squat ready
to
do this whatever it is never mind them
not doing that okay how the way um Sue's
me oh there we go okay
all right you got this oh okay stealthy
stealthy I'm stealthy healthy I'm a
healthy stealthy oh I see how we do oh I
see I see I see how we're doing
oh I see I see what we got going on here
oh good good good good so far so good
oh man you should see me he used to see
me I have a theory yes uh-uh no no that
didn't well uh no no no no no no no no
no no no hey who's that who's that man
why is her man down there oh and hello
sir Wow look at that folks we made it
got to finish the mission
yeah what an exciting and entertaining
lead plate someone must have dropped
something next time sorry about that
folks
and he's done it a massive thank you to
Matt for helping us clear out our
calendar today and open the way for a
new show starting next week stay tuned
for a sneak peak trailer right after
these messages from our sponsors what
did you just make me do what did you
make me do who's sane I'm not doing this
[ __ ] no I'm done wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
tonight's just shoot someone out here it
is that game is that game just who's
they built for dude I didn't even make
that connection whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
they may not kill some anti stacy mark i
who was it another contestant i think
they're one of the rooms near a second
the gunshot from the living room
whatever they made you do it wasn't your
fault and you know that if they were
killing off another character it was
going to happen still it was just a game
you know stupid game they were trying to
advertise or something hello as you
enjoying it until i realized so make me
kill someone with the game states what
the [ __ ] is wrong with these people
[Music]
don't let them get you mad you're
stronger than they are
you've got to stay strong for julia okay
post of us and i mean it I won't leave
you this day see where's the first place
we'd want to go I think I'd go to a bar
and just get absolutely hammered try to
forget about all this for just one night
that or an ice cream parlor
[Music]
I think I want to go away so my open
honks feel the breeze and space around
me somewhere natural I know so sick of
feeling boxed and I've nothing been real
me and you used to just sit on the couch
you know before all this
the thought of hiking around outdoors is
a fate worse than death no I just kill
to feel the rain on my face again yeah
and we'd have to keep the touch you know
Pleasant a person no soon as I'm out if
he eras over between us I've got a
reputation to uphold you know it's one
of the cool kids besides I don't think
jr. will want me hanging around too much
you and her have a life to rebuild
I mean without your wonder made it this
far okay if I don't have you to talk to
and I've got mad seasons ago and to be
honest I can't imagine I bet this this
right here right now this this
interaction is the real show like this
is the real show everyone like everyone
in this thing thinks it's the other
thing like it's out there but of course
that's a stupid no one would actually
want that right okay
good tip thank you yeah I bet this is
the crazy idea that they were they were
talking about yeah it's gotta be right
oh okay oh man land of low framerate
thank you very much
which I could actually see some [ __ ]
okay this game is interesting it's got
it it's got quite a story here there's
something going on deeper and I like
about a game like the mechanics of it
are a little janky it's a little baking
simulator esque but at the same time
it's good cuz it draws me in okay what's
this
hello conference room number fo ah okay
close the dough get only ten frames
perfect okay the Harper situation has
gotten out of control is one thing
having him loose in the building this is
another entirely and what this matter
solved immediately if he makes contact
with any other stars who knows what
could happen until it is resolved all
uses of the grinder are to be suspended
and the thorough investigation is to be
conducted ah yes the company cellphone
with the only grinder app installed on
it if you can control contain him you
know the protocol site awaits his
arrival can't afford anymore containment
reaches containment breaches you say AHA
ce-5 reclamation notice c4 following the
passing of your security team liaison we
still find several personnel effects
absent from a collection we're still
missing an ID badge for Kay Robinson I
expect this to be found and brought to
security room ASAP we do not need
another breach there's a chance he still
has it on him the new green room code is
one eight four six five one okay I got
one
a oh wow eight folk hmm got it want a
fuss if I want okay so I just got to
find the security room with my two
frames a second try to find it whoa whoa
whoa I'm not doing anything
Harry's green room isn't that the one
green room key yeah Oh No
oh um great folks great taste since
nineteen series of history
uh oh wait no hang on wait no no no no
no no no no no no no how is this this is
not fair this is not fair no no no no no
no no no I Bob okay nevermind then I
guess okay trying it you okay let's
assume that he just left me right where
I was yeah did okay did it did it's the
amnesia style of stuff who is this
doctor something something I don't know
who is this where is this hello hello no
apparently not yeah this is the time to
pontificate all right I don't know what
that is that's computer go I don't know
what that is either
so weird okay as I'm sure you've heard
the recent exposure to the public has
resulted in a need to transition
facilities while governing bodies are
squeezed of their fears to ensure the
protection of all assets and transit
we're asking that you make a detailed
catalog of any items and their stars
that are removed subject for removal by
the appropriate date will be transferred
to grinder and repurposed for future
endeavors grinder ensure our programming
stays fresh reading program I saw in
there that's as lovely as lovely but
this doesn't look like the security room
so something about a breeding program
what the hell does that even mean what
does it even mean why are we here are we
Soylent are we solid green Oh such low
frame rate gotta be the security room
around here somewhere well if I wrap
around the other way I should be able to
get out of this is it just a big loop oh
it is hey don't come back here by the
way just don't come back here so you're
coming back here no you're not no the
security room yes it is
okay Sakura tah hello hi hi diddly hol
this is why it's lagging cuz there's so
many cameras everywhere oh that that's
that's what they call bad okay hey hey
listen listen listen listen listen
let's don't do air
okay all right I must smoke some
Prichard please arrive promptly that's
so sweet
hey mr. blinky how are you doing today
oh don't be so glum cheer up Shawn yeah
well you know he said the same thing
yesterday but I talk good you know yeah
hello can you [ __ ] hear me I said
the door's locked open the open the door
I can't I can't get into the living room
if you don't open the [ __ ] door
if you think I'm gonna sit here and get
punished because of your shitty door
then you've got another thing coming
from the producers face live with
radiant and always fabulous host Jean
Osmond and here's the guy you've been
waiting for put your hands together for
the one the only
Matt hey foods pretty close there Matt
you wouldn't want to keep the lovely
people at home waiting well you know me
you know I like to keep it exciting for
the folks at home I know you do
well Matt why don't you tell us what
you'll be doing today today I'm gonna be
sending an email to a fun of the show
that's great it doesn't say their name
though sounds fantastic why don't we
make our way to your office and get
started my office
oh boy Oh hahaha farts odds are here
okay alright Here I am okay PC log in
what's nowhere but somewhere except
where something is oh okay you really
got me stumped over this one you get
really stumped over a barrel on this one
what's nowhere but somewhere except
where something is nothing nothing okay
how do I put in the nothing I see that I
see it so oh maybe I just type no no no
okay well maybe I sit oh I got sit down
Oh got it
yeah baby all right let's play game
boink okay one away whoo all right
there's one wait no it's right good we
all know we all know this oh yeah
whatever
okay CMD maybe there's something like
whoa
[Music]
okay so we got the tesseract out of
there I don't know what that did but
apparently worden oh well let's just go
to email all right I guess so well here
we go extracting data mail config all
right 24 there we go
rearrange following string to make
passwords oh right the passwords Julia
ah and we did it wasn't so bad was it
folks
okay so let's send this email who's the
look in front of the show uh-huh
now Matt one of my uncle's once told me
that was great power comes great
responsibility you better use those
newfound skills for good wouldn't want
there to be any negative repercussions
no we wouldn't okay
tentacle hentai your monthly
subscription to 1000 send bank account
information to get money from Arabian
Prince good great always love when I get
that money now
buy my book coins okay buy my pants
what's up all right
Oh would you look at that to my to to my
dear friend Julia yes why did I get up
in here anyway
Oh Matt you joke are you careful what
you say now there you go it's a lovely
message to do it gee dear Julia I can't
remember the last time I spoke to you
and I'm sorry it's been so long when I
last saw you we didn't leave on the best
of terms but I hope you know it's all
forgiven
I found a record of our song the other
day reminded me of our first date
let's meet up soon I miss you more than
I can express in this email losing you
was a mistake and I should have tried
harder to get you back funnily enough
I've been thinking about how to reach
you recently so I'm glad we got this
chance to talk I hope you know that I
haven't given up on us on being together
again
next time we speak I hope it'll be face
to face and not via email
don't stop believing in us in me we can
still be together and soon we will be
you always said my determination was one
of my best features so I hope knowing
I'm still determined to be there for you
will help over the next few weeks keep
an eye on maybe I'll make my way to your
end of the woods soon until then stay
strong beautiful I've never stopped
loving you yours forever man
sad well folks wait and see well that's
all we have time for this week folks
will Matt receive a reply or will he be
left cold and alone tune in next week
for more crazy action what so it's a
week between these things okay all right
we'll do you you got it hope no one's
mad at me for going against the rules
okay
easy peasy are there like individual
shows going on too tonight you're just
going to get caught again Matt and
eventually they're going to get tired of
bringing you back well with an attitude
like that he might as well just give up
and wait to be cancelled look I'm sorry
I can't be enthusiastic every time but
I'm worried about you Matt if they take
you and you don't come back what am I
meant to do it'll just be me alone in
this [ __ ]
Stacy I'm sorry okay I'm scared too but
if I start listening to that voice the
one that telling me I'm I'm gonna get
myself killed and to stay put that I'm
never going to get going again someone
out there is trying to help us okay and
if they still think that we can do it
then we have to trust them you don't
even know who they are Matt what if it's
another game
some stupid task they've thought up to
boost ratings they're not gonna put on
one hell of a shelf room they're gonna
regret what they've done to us to Julia
okay all right I guess it's settled
she's the life Stacy okay they wouldn't
have bothered danglars are in front of
me if she wasn't okay they think me
knowing they still have will make me
behave fall in line and play their game
and they are wrong when I was brought
here after what I did I was ready to
give up and let them do whatever they
wanted to me Stacy I wanted to die I
spent months just blindly following
orders
wasting away as my show's ratings slowly
declined and then you arrived you made
me see that no matter what happened
before this isn't how it should end I
kept fighting because I couldn't let you
down I couldn't just let myself die and
leave you here after all you've done for
me you kept me alive Matt you gave me my
spark back and if I let you run yourself
into the grave with these pointless
escape attempts that I could never
forgive myself
think about Julia mark
about me what do we do when you're gone
I'm sorry I know it's risky and I know
how this will probably end up I cannot
stop now I've got to keep going until
either we're all out of here or I'm gone
I'm not gonna be part of this anymore
Stacy I'm not gonna sit here and let
them decide when we die good on you good
on your mat good on you that'll really
boost the ratings this is compelling
[ __ ] oh hello
we're live why does it say we're alive
I'm opening the outer door yeah thanks
okay alright but how are they changing
things and also a lap etapa lap but
tapas should I spy on producer wait spy
on producer let me see if there was a
new email nope dad nothing did nothing
nothing for nobody Paul my spy on that
producer
well that producer is gonna be spied
upon hi wait a minute is this dodge with
this the doing of their security team
thing no I can't deal with boxes all
those pieces of Pope oh they know me
well I'm gonna get down oh I'm gonna get
them all right oh wait that wasn't even
the way that was never behind it they
didn't mess with me I didn't know he was
going to leave the bloody thing open
anybody's bare I swear to God if he
doesn't get his [ __ ] together I'm
putting him on his own show we'll see
how funny it is to forget your ass every
five seconds look I know it's a breach
of security yes I realized what could've
happened if a star had have got hold of
it I assure you it won't happen again we
reset the code dowon's faithful Tony's
computer in the West Wing
and will be said to get out of the memos
of all I think it's password-protected
so if you need to get on but urgently
give Tony a shout and I'm sure he can
help you that's fine no it's okay he's a
[ __ ] you've every right to be annoyed
okay okay
quite talking to you okay all right
Dolores okay so something about a
password something about hacking
something about going sneaking or what
you doing over there okay goodbye
all right so either way I gotta find my
way around here get what I need to get
don't get what I don't need to get and
then be gone I don't know what they'd be
doing to change the environment here to
make it more difficult on me but oh hey
that is just a weird neighbor that you
do I don't like that I also find it a
little odd find it a little odd that
they you know just so happened to make
me play a video game that's kind of
close to this security control unit okay
access controls um um ah I hit green on
all of them okay so everything's been
unlocked Barry just that easy huh all
right just that easy easy easy lemon
squeeze the marketing department is now
open but is he looped okay he's in the
back let's not go that we're just here
oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] what is happening
here you just uh you just can't can't
figure out what that cow is huh whoo I'm
gonna just like oh I got by that okay
acquisition Oh
I don't look good all right I can't stay
here though gotta keep movin
oh I've already been in here okay I've
been in here yeah that's the lovely
mystery meeting room which is
very fun and then there's the marketing
department so it's either gonna be in
this one or the other one on some other
door that I unlocked I don't know what
Jesus so most got problem Hugh Bruton
okay I can't see [ __ ] I don't even know
what I'm looking for here uh slander
assault degrading behavior great love it
love it all all that what was the point
of coming in here get out of here oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] well we're fine
everything's hunky Dickey going I'm just
gonna gun it for the opposite end don't
think that he'd come in here if it was
already supposed to be locked
oh please hurry please okay acquisitions
what is this all about
there's some laser wires here okay I
don't know what I'm supposed to do but I
obviously can't go through there unless
I'm supposed to use that one don't
supposed to do no I can't even can't
even open that okay oh now they're both
looking at that either one stuck in
front of the other one or they're both
looking at that oh well that's handy I
guess is it good or bad
whoa I don't know what that was you just
did but it was awesome oh please don't
do that to me Dolores Finkelstein wait
Dolores Dolores if this is Dolores room
then that means Dolores would have a
code somewhere here maybe that's what I
need was there
oh well there must be some password here
somewhere
oh here we go here we go I found a
computer that's open okay so oh sandy oh
[ __ ] wait sandy sandy isn't that the
name of the person next door to me isn't
sandy the name of the person that was
next door to me sandy I talked to Sandy
Oh
hell yeah sandy what was that I couldn't
even tell her moved it's dark something
happened
okay uh here we go here we go here we go
here we go okay hi Sam
sorry this is so last-minute but Dolores
and HR rang me last night about Dave's
messing with her laptop can you check it
one five one seven seven okay one five
one seven seven that's a little close
for my taste one five one seven seven
one five one seven seven is that Dolores
is that might be Dolores is okay so I
need to go to Dolores the lower ass are
here we go one five one seven seven got
it
bingo bango oh gosh [ __ ] oh okay all
right your tentacle aah after five years
of subscription you recently let your
payment lapse please log on and enter
your new payment details don't we'd be
forced to terminate your account best
wishes ten tickles Oh Dolores oh come on
please be aware of pressing concerns
about protocol compromised have forced
us to up the timeline on the move the
new date is 27th okay sorry to have to
change the combination again 5437 62
okay easy enough but I need to turn off
the lasers
I'm sick of finding his presence more
issues with Dave oh he's frankly
obsessed with me sandy he's using DF
sucks dick as his security and password
after the last disciplinary okay
DF sucks dick okay DF got it okay gotta
write that one down I'll never be able
to remember that apologies for
disturbing you at work I picked up some
Harry's mystery meat for tonight I just
wondered if you wanted anything to go
with it about the junior version I know
you prefer the tender still Oh Mick says
he wants to shift the show running in
the coming weeks that means you're on
day shift rather than I should have took
that's okay only a big change of
lifestyle okay let's try that one on the
other one that we have over there
oh no the security that's security man
okay so we got to put DF suck stick into
the security
computer and then we've got things down
to business oh we are making progress
now okay all right here we go here we go
here we go here we go here we go here we
go
DF sucks dick oh yeah oh yeah oh hell
yes system clear extracting data oh oh
yeah oh yeah security shut down engage
section 1 grid off section 2 grid off
such as very good
unable to disengage containment pens
grid off meat processing alarm shutdown
yeah it seems like not important
yeah yeah that's that's probably fine
alright how about big old DF so dark I
log in and my beautiful obsession sandy
are sandy whoa alright got in okay quick
update on the breach we've been unable
to locate asset to server thrown on one
since our escape whilst we believe them
to be dead due to an incident when the
grinder we ask that all employees remain
vigilant okay Dave enough is enough chop
changing my pooping email password is
not interested in the date fix my
password change your password darling
it's watching you ah
that's creepy as hell although I guess
in a place where they're processing
humans on a TV show I guess it should
just be par for the course
alright due to this discourse we find
ourselves an unwanted scrutiny and
whilst the leak has sent to Harry's
green room oh the leak has been sent we
must take appropriate action effective
immediately the operation is to begin
shutdown and preparations for relocation
or to be made gonna do big business your
potty plenty of suckers around its
promised I fixed our little sandy issue
got them looking elsewhere she's safe oh
that's nice okay I can now get into
Sandy's email if I wanted to which I do
oh [ __ ] so it's now watching you which
is definitely not creepy in any way
shape or form BAM okay we're here again
okay vacation time approves starting for
two weeks have a great trip CNS
souvenirs bring me something back okay
we cannot have producers that are unable
to maintain control of their assets to
7:09 and one remains your responsibility
in any damage
cause we'll be taken out on you
personally I swear I swear sandy isn't
sandy the name of the person next door
it's over sandy I can't keep lying to
her we had some fun it was great don't
contact me again she cannot know Oh
Charles is Dolores is I gotcha okay well
here we are say any funny how things
change isn't it I dealt with that little
problem we discussed and now meat
production is missing a crew member
Everest a lot helping you the least you
can do is give me a date I'll pick you
up tomorrow wear something nice we
wouldn't want our secret getting out
Dave kiss kiss kiss kiss kiss kiss dear
sandy just want to confirm I've received
your latest complaint I'll be contacting
the estate's about Dave and recommending
he be immediately enrolled in his own
show one of the ones with a lower
survival right so I'll go through I'll
make sure you're there for the premiere
whoa what did I do
Oh Status compromised immediate
extraction
advised proceed to evac alpha okay all
right well doc I don't know what that is
but dye did that good for me I really
did it I did it I'm so proud of myself
oh hi oh he's gonna warp he's gonna
warped okay he's not gonna want don't
say that don't say that dad II think II
oh hi
whoa hey how you doing there um listen
we can talk about this right oh I just
got a key okay all right I'll do that
cancel me and I'm not ready for that
I'll give it my op in case I don't make
it
you fill the void mr. blinky how's it
going great to see you again now Matt
normally we let you decide what fun
activity you'll be sharing with our
audience but today we thought we'd do
something a little different
keep you on your toes sounds interesting
what have you got for me
in front of you you'll find a map in
several clues these will lead you on an
exciting scavenger hunt with a shocking
conclusion you won't see coming great I
can't wait to see what the prize is you
have till the end of the episode to
finish but don't take too long you don't
want to miss out on your prize my prize
is it a face first trip into the grinder
is that my prize ooh
cancel I don't know what that means but
okay
ah I'm so excited oh my god I'm okay I'm
bursting with excitement I literally I'm
gonna explode if I don't if I don't know
exactly what the excitements all about
where's my clue wait I see something in
here
a lighter you're talking about a you're
talking about a match sealed behind
glass memories capture two last three me
you gaze upon yourself and see you're
talking about the picture oh wait that's
where don't ever let me get a pen yeah
go make for good ratings
okay so a world trapped in flicker
light you talk about the fireplace
flickering light ah you imagine me in
Julia's first date
breaking down for three hours at a gas
station wasn't exactly what I had in
mind but a rousing game of air freshener
critique was more fun than I thought
yeah okay trapped in flickering light
the world world o war on a TV I'm always
running the butt of the joke but I give
them a cold reception the fridge the
fridge is running scratched by a needle
spoon on a plate from me comes emotion
it's a record player is so simple mad
you found all the clues and claimed the
final piece of the puzzle we couldn't be
prouder of you big guy now return to the
living room to receive your reward
envelope yet though you'll spoil the
surprise I bet I'm gonna like that I bet
I bet I bet you're gonna make me pick
between that did you enjoy the scavenger
hunt today oh I had a blast why don't
you open envelope and find out what you
won I can't wait let's see what slow
down there champ
we're getting to it now show the
audience what you found hold it up to
the camera that's right folks those two
lovely ladies and the leading influences
in Matt's life both of them cherished
companions he couldn't do without isn't
that just lovely horse times are tight
and neither of these lady shows have
been achieving the ratings we've hoped
for if we keep running our business like
this well we'll go bust and you wouldn't
want that now would you would you mad no
this is a joke right you wouldn't do
this in front of the folks at home
please don't please don't do this
leave them alone it's not all bad though
we've scrounge together down deep into
the compendiums piggy bank and pulled
our birthday money to ensure that one of
these shows
stay on the air sadly that means one has
to go though and you know what that
means folks it's time to normally this
sort of decision would be left to the
higher-ups but as both these lovelies
are Matt's bows we thought we'd reward
his recent behavior by giving him the
choice of who gets to stay and who gets
cancelled
oops I'm sorry I'm sorry that I tried to
get out okay no to take out on me not
them Matt in front of you are two
buttons one for Stacy and one for Julia
make your choice buddy who gets to stay
on the air and who's gonna be sent home
choose quickly though because if the
timer runs out and you haven't made a
choice we'll have to cancel both do this
don't don't don't make me do this no
please the clock's ticking Matt who's it
gonna be the love of your life or the
woman who's kept you sane all these
years it's a tough choice I'm glad I
don't have to make it [ __ ] you now
that's not very showman like only 20
seconds left you don't want them both to
get cancelled do you Matt will do this
please stop don't make juice eight seven
six five four three
I'm not gonna play your game well I'm
not a slave to you [ __ ] you I'm not the
one killing him you are Hayes Christ
you're not gonna you do oh you got
choose yeah well do something I didn't
[ __ ] do anything yeah screw you
yeah screw you and everything you stand
for bunch of stupid trying to make me
agonize over something and this is like
this is a tough choice it is a tough
choice like it's like normally if I had
to make a choice I would probably lean
towards Julia but I'm never gonna be
like that you like I'm not gonna do
anything I'm like [ __ ] you just straight
up [ __ ] you oh that's what that's what
Stacy looked like oh hi Stacy Stacy in
case I didn't know and Julia
so apparently the game was not equipped
to deal with me not making the choice
here okay so let me just read
reason to this because now it's like the
game won't progress if I don't do
something this is one of those
situations where I can't fully relate to
how the character feeling because
obviously I haven't spent five years
doing the same repetitive [ __ ] over
and over again not hearing like his wife
or someone or whoever this is to him and
like talking to Stacy obviously has kept
him sane but at the same time it's like
there would still be something deep in
my heart for Julia and so given the
limited knowledge that I have in the
situation that I'm in I have to go with
Julia like and cancel Stacy like that's
just the way that my brain right now is
working and because on only because the
game is telling me that I can't go on
and it was giving me that fake crap
about like rule cancel both and it's
like okay whatever here we go
congratulations Matt thanks to you Julia
gets another season to prove herself
though we can't say the same for Stacy
to think all these years you've kept
each other sane supported each other
through thick and thin it was almost
like you were married hopefully she'll
forgive your betrayal why don't we check
in and see no no no oops too late
congratulations again Matt now say
goodbye to the audience I'm gonna stop
not till I get out of here and find
every last one of you you hear me I'll
[ __ ] kill another day another wild
adventure what will Matt get up to next
find out next time on captive audience
broadcast ended please use this free
time to better yourself before the next
performance it's so weird I mean number
one what a cop-out on the game if I'm
not gonna make a choice and you say
you're gonna kill both kill both like
because I don't want to be forced in a
situation like that but yeah that's that
just sucks just emotionally like that
does suck but then again I don't know
what's real here look is any of this
real is this part of the story is this
the comp
thing what's the reality you can pay but
I'm gonna die trying
welp better shower before I go out there
again I can't even look at the painting
anymore well that is what it is
I lost the plan I'm gonna punch one of
those eyeball BOTS the producer wanted
to view this episode in person he's here
Matt this is your best chance for
revenge make your way towards the
central control room take them out
escape
find him Matt find him and make him pay
I'm opening the outer door you make your
way out of the apartment and down the
corridor don't forget what you've
learned don't get caught
Roger that you'd think that they would
post like a live guard if they really
wanted to keep me out that's why I think
this is all just part of the show like
there's some deeper level here like if
this is I'm reminded of that black
mirror episode where they had the person
being punished over and over again as in
a show maybe that's where this is
inspired from because that concept that
concept that it's like you are here and
you are being punished whoa hey hey whoa
whoa hey whoa I didn't die wait a minute
wait wait a minute
Oh what are you doing oh whoa oh he's
he's a grumpy here you go on okay
goodbye
what happened what just oh well what the
hell's happening here what the hell
happened
okay well that's weird it Oh
Epping oh now I'm not much for revenge
but I do admit this does put a smile on
my face
allo oh I'm not controlling this now so
completely out of my hands
ah what beautiful music to club
someone's brains in
[Music]
yeah I don't I don't trust this
something's not right
that's a quite a rag doll testing
testing one two one two
congratulations Matt wrap on season five
[Applause]
you had us worried there for a minute
you know I thought you might give up
after that last task but no no you stuck
to your guns and Matt were proud of you
before we drag you back to your room for
a well-deserved rest we probably give
you a special reward so here to present
you is the lead producer and now senior
executive of the network stay Reynold
get over here you
Thank You Jean gosh it's been a long run
hasn't it
I thought we were going to have a
problem near the end there Matt Oh Matt
you gave us quite the scare before we
got that fire burning again I didn't
expect after it dying to get you off
your ass
I think masters in the round of applause
everybody don't you
[Applause]
well now that brings us to our special
reward Matt you came here in the dark
not even knowing if she was still alive
now live I'm captive audience I can
confirm to you
julia is alive give a round of applause
for Julia folks starburst Saturday
morning our take a look for yourself
Matt let me tell you Matt your love
story has gripped the nation this season
we've achieve higher viewer ratings and
satisfaction than any other show out
there your desperate struggle to escape
you're trying to rescue Julia and your
confusion about your feelings for Stacie
have held our audience there I say
[Applause]
every star of the show with the people
[Music]
to the top I owe it all to you let's
give him another round of applause folks
[Applause]
now we've got a party to get started so
we're gonna send you back to your room
with the help of our lovely guards oh
and Matt we've got one last surprise for
you
Stacey will you do the honors you've
been approved for five do you know how
amazing that is and now I'm in too much
I've got two great ideas with lemonade
[Music]
we've got a long road ahead but I can't
wait to take it with you don't be though
[Music]
damn man I'm I'm glad I stuck through
that like the game like the mechanics of
it we're really wonky but I could tell
that there was a story that I really
wanted to know about and that was really
good it was one of those situations
where they the game itself almost
detracted itself from the story like the
gameplay itself was almost detrimental
to the story because that story was
great and it was almost impeding me from
continuing but that was really cool I
mean I kind of called it and you could
kind of see where it was going with that
one but it was really well done it was
really well made but I bet there's more
secrets to that because like I don't
know what it was with the secret bug
that I unlocked or something like that
like the secret like little doodad or
thing and I'm sorry for the low frame
rates right now like I said the game a
little a little problematic so sometimes
here and there but it's just like
there's some really cool ideas coming
out of this and it's like
well that was a message Julia okay and I
think that's it but yeah there's a lot
of really cool concepts coming out of
here and thank you everybody so much for
sticking with it too because there was
like it was it was a little I would like
I've said it's a little little little
rough around the edges pretty rough road
yeah just but it made for good stuff now
there was there's probably more secrets
in this because there's a ton of
achievements that I was getting can I
see that
achievements let me restart I want to
see the achievements yeah because there
was some secrets like seeing Julia's
picture every day like that was a simple
thing I didn't do everything every day
here we go okay so I got a lot of stuff
I didn't get all the mini games oh
that's something blinkie's adventure oh
I could have taken blinky with me Oh
uncover the Compendium leak okay I did
that cries at the dam can you hear him
in the darkness no I haven't no first
contact is a friend or foe I don't know
friend in a bag aren't they supposed to
be dead Oh Oh will you shut up heard
enough the Sheep bad puns this den
caught by drone five times
Dave's email spied on producer every
night oh I missed one of those on Bessie
blink C's family cousin blankie
Blanca puts grayer what did I find
Blanca the betrayer you are not alone
12:22 what does that mean what is this
one okay so there's there's some more
secrets here but that is the end of
captive audience this is a really cool
concept I like it a lot just needs some
work
on optimization actually making the game
itself work well because I mean those
are things that really do matter like it
really does matter because yeah you
gotta have like that drive to it you got
to have like the game has to be a game I
mean it's like a good story but like the
game has to work as a game so but that's
all I'll say about so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
developers for making this this was
really really cool and just like I can't
wait to see what comes out of it more
like I want to see Julie's story I want
to know that this story was great so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought down the
comments below if you want to support
this channel and help me make cool stuff
click that join button and become a
member of the channel today so thanks
again everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]